so would i want harry kane in my team 99
of the people watching ain't me they're
not west ham fans they're not watched
antonio go from a right back to the best
striker in the league great story you
know what i mean so but
it's not gonna change the fact right now
because this is when the question is i'm
having antonio
[Music]
right sunshine easy yes i'm ready that's
good i'm very good thank you sunshine me
off already yeah
west ham are currently a better team
than spurs
three
two
one
yeah
all right i'll give you that
currently 100 better team than you guys
um
and if you're looking at
where we can get to personally and i
know you have just got kante and
i don't know how you feel as a spurs fan
but for me looking from the outside in
um i don't think the players that
kante's got there are gonna match to his
spirit
for me it seems over the years
you know what i'm going to say this
whole spursie thing and i think that
comes as a whole club and a whole aura
like mourinho coming in you see it in
that whole
all or nothing you're not a bunch of
[ __ ] really
so
all right the question was about whether
or not
west ham are better side than the
tottenham as well right now
that's all right
but but the fact is is that at that time
of recording you know you're marginally
above us we've had an absolute nightmare
start to the season you're your main guy
your captain well you got your captain
your main guy though he don't want to be
there like factually doesn't want to be
there um your keeper he ain't the same
keeper as he was before so all these
good players that you had that were on
the way up the delhi's all these players
you had the two best fallbacks going
back to when potter was there it's all
gone you had the two best center backs
yeah toby and yan like it's a terrible
team right now all these teams at the
moment this goes for west ham as well
the leadership ain't great but if you're
looking at a club in the premier league
and you're like alright
who would i want to be who whose fans
would i want to be right now
west ham west ham fans are happier than
tottenham fans are right now that's fair
i'll give you that even your main
striker harry kane one of our own yeah
we've got one of our own as well and
declan yeah we see him every game he
loves it he loves it at western you
don't want to go how long another one's
there
there is no integrity in this game it's
money and it's opportunity i think
declan is one of the few players with
integrity we'll see and i don't want to
tell stories of deck and all of this but
um yeah man i know stories are off deck
and
which i won't say i don't know why i
said i'm gonna
yeah don't
uh for 400 grand would a week would
erase any story that you have with him
no you'll change your opinion about that
like that i think he's just like you
don't think that's on the table for him
now probably yeah exactly bro of course
it is he's the best mate
you're a couple of players away from
this all falling apart yeah yeah
declan white
you know antonio yeah antonio is crucial
and and and that's the thing is the
difference between tottenham west ham is
your current situation i would argue is
fleeting and tottenham's
success is inevitability
you might have your day in the sun but
the sun goes down but the sun's up now
yeah it goes down yeah the sun's up now
only human son would currently make it
into west ham starting
come on three oh sorry
sorry that sorry
did you what do you want to do again let
everyone know you went early what an
appalling statement where are you going
trying to think how many spurs players
would get into my current west damn team
none of your fallbacks the question was
would son get sun's only one this is it
yes i'm saying that so you strongly
disagree
i had to think about it hang on a minute
exactly
i was strongly a strong no i disagree
100 disagree do you think more players
can get into my west ham team yeah
absolutely
i would say right now
i would say
oliver skip
above who
are you
what are you yes you check my rice
four nails spanish international
this ain't no joke you know skip is good
skit's good i like it let's give it
harry winks we ain't going to get in the
west ham team
this is what i'm saying sorry that i'm
taking time because i just don't want to
like an idiot what lucas moore he
wouldn't get in harry kane wouldn't get
in so who am i taking out because i'm
not taking that jared bowen from lucas
morale personally he is on form because
you got remember the way that i'm
looking at and this is the way i look at
football bro it's like
there's certain players that are great
but they ain't gonna come into a david
moyes team and run back and do well son
would to be fair he works hard he could
fit into a moisty team when we finish in
champions league position we might sign
him off here to be honest with you um
you know what
i strongly agree
that son
my guy i love him the only one that's
trying to work hard for your team at the
moment um loris would get in we're
releasing lorries will get to the west
no not not this larisse because he would
not this lorise he's won a world cup
what does that mean what was john
charlie's one john o'shea's won the
champions league you know trust me i'm
one of them guys bro i don't care squad
player squad player man but laurice is
good but i wouldn't even have him as
first choice for france right now
personally romero
he would get him i watched ramirez the
other day bro play for you guys and in
the first half he went down four times
and one of the times he rolled over six
times this is the center half and we
spoke i'm a defender so when i see
defenders rolling over six times after
they've been touched by a striker i'm
not on it bro i would have took him at
the team there and then very tricky
question he asked because he made it
puts
it's luckier
yeah i just want to say that i'll
happily move it slightly towards here
right oh [ __ ] i just remembered where
you was yeah get that question no no
categorically not saying that the sun is
the only player good enough to play for
west ham right can i go through your
midfields i asked you to name your
midfielder from here is it well it's
we're playing a free for free so
and skip
and they're not
on a current level then they're not sue
check them right and this is what i have
to deal with with spurs fans but even
just agree with you you're midfielder
you're midfield though and i'm gonna go
with your midfield and your defense only
two players
maybe three maybe freak was your keeper
but this is the keeper from years ago
you gotta move your your point glass a
little bit over because you said two you
the question was about i'm gonna take my
small win here right you give me two
right without begging
100 and you should be there
you should be there
you should be there this could be a
first by the way you should be there no
chance come on i can't play it right now
that a spurs
team that can get in the west hampton i
can't believe i'm getting my ass handed
to me like this this is unreal like i
said it should be if you don't mind me
touching then you can touch it yeah
there mate
let's do the next question i'd rather
have mikhail antonio in my team than
harry kane
three
two one
oh christ
you can't have the conversation about
harry kane and antonio and not talk
about what they are as as players and
what they've done previously
harry kane
walks into
any team
any team in the premier league actually
right now
it doesn't matter right now you know
he's coming back you know he's coming
back december
2021
harry kane walks into any team in the
premiership right now premier league
show my age there in in um what i'm
saying is that if you're talking about
form and you want someone for the next
90 minutes to do a job maybe there's a
shout for antonio maybe
but harry kane's quality means that no
matter how out of form he is the next 90
minutes could be the best he's had in
his career in fact man city the best
team at you know the
best in the league they won the league
wanted to buy him and couldn't afford
him just goes to show how in demand
harry kane you think harry kane harry
kane could score 10 goals this season
and there will be a
a list of clubs longer than my arm that
would want to sign it no that wouldn't
be the same for antonio so you just
can't
but it doesn't it doesn't matter about
four there is one stat though that um is
gonna make sense today and that's one
goal that he scored in the premier
league this season and that one goal is
what you think is going to get him
against a guy
that's at the top of the charts in
antonio i'm telling you that 99 of the
people watching this would pick harry
kane over antonio
in
this in spite of hurricanes form
and antonio's form
because it doesn't matter because if you
know who's
most likely to deliver because of their
quality what was the question
honestly seriously
that would be quite poor
i could ask
okay
i'd rather have mikhail antonio in my
team than harry kane
and for how long
how long would you rather have an
antonio in your team than harry harry
kane maybe for the next game or two so
would i want harry kane in my team 99 of
the people watching ain't me they're not
west ham fans they're not watched
antonio go from a right back to the best
striker in the league great story you
know what i mean so but it's not don't
change the fact
is hurricane better than antonio's
player play for player yes yes
right now because this is when the
question is 20th
2021 right december like
i'm having antonio okay i'm having
antonio and guess what he's jamaican i'm
jamaican look what's there like one bro
well i'm gonna argue
both of those things are facts oh yeah
it's a tough one for me no yeah i mean i
like all i can say is that
there isn't there's there's no one out
there hurricanes better than antonio i'm
not not an idiot most yeah but most
people out there aren't jamaican and
they're not
they don't care that antonio is jamaican
so for that reason i'm gonna have to say
without a shadow of a doubt you know
it's gonna be hurricane antonio conte
made the wrong decision joining spurs
three
two
you you come on just do your thing bro
but i'm here i'm in between agree and
strongly okay disagree mate go ahead
strongly agree sorry because no yeah i'm
going to oh yeah i'm going to put it you
would you have to
manage i like that um
i don't know the only reason i can see
that he joins spurs is that
it's a bigger club i'm gonna say it's a
big club it's a bigger club um it got
his juices flowing man united wasn't
available we all know this is the truth
mate yeah man united was available conte
goes in there
and he builds you know what i mean by
only for probably two years as he always
does freeze the rumor was that he wanted
to go to manchester united man spurs and
peratti showed up and they just
it just they they just it was too much
to turn down perhaps he said look we are
a big football club you can come over
and do what you want all i think brother
what i've got here is i don't think he's
staying
um i think i personally think the way
football's going at the moment we could
see end of the season he going to united
still and saying you know what what the
end of this season no chance no no
why definitely not
football no no lie when you said this
earlier there's nothing in it like no
more well i mean there's always a chance
you can know exactly
we know he wants to go united you know
the likelihood of that is minimal but
there is a child you know you can he's
he you don't know that you just keep
saying we know you don't know anything
about what's going on i just know
football bro there's no footwork at the
moment the disloyalty in football it
wasn't okay sorry wouldn't surprise you
yes there you go look nothing surprises
me but nothing would surprise me so but
harry kane's behavior in the summer
didn't this it you know
didn't surprise me because
everybody in football fundamentally and
as human beings you're looking at doing
the best for yourself right well we've
done the best for spurs harry kane sorry
to go for harry quickly but he had done
the best for spurs and this is why going
back to kante why he should leave the
end of the season because spurs fans
football fans what you're saying i feel
like because i'm not saying it's okay
the way harry kane behaved because of
everything good before so if you're
having a lovely relationship with a
beautiful woman or man whatever you're
into
and you're not you i mean anybody i'm
just trying to keep inclusive the the um
that uh that you're having a wonderful
relationship brilliant like food pies
sex everything's amazing right
and then she cheats on you at the end
you don't think about all the good times
ago all right fair enough off you go do
you you go
oh you cheated on me
what about all the good times
if i had a harry kane and he cheats on
me
hey come back harry
harry
harry
i disrespected him now he feels we were
disrespected yeah man you're not like
why did you just respond to that
you know that levy double-crossed him
that's nothing's doing me
but you as a human you know hurricanes
feeling awake like it's like you know
what i found the contract that's not my
fault it's not my fault as a fan you you
as a supporter you said you're not good
enough for me anymore so yeah back to
that because of all that's going on with
harry kane may if i'm kante i stay well
away from spurs mate um but i guess we
don't agree again that's good that's
there it should be by the way
i think kante made a hell of a mistake
signing for spurs he wanted to go united
um
and then make your choice completely
disagree right club at the right time
money to spend it's perfect match
spurs will finish above west ham in the
premier league this season
three
two one
oh
that's respectful yeah i think we will
as well not not strong no i don't know
you you think we're standby you disagree
that spurs will finish above
that's not the question just gonna save
you there thank you that's right you're
welcome stephen
no
no i'm not gonna do you think spurs will
finish above west ham i have to back
spurs because that's that's my team
right
if it was still luna in charge
i couldn't see i couldn't see spurs
finishing above west ham you are a
really good side and this isn't a
ridiculous question this is a good
question and it's difficult to answer
but i have so much faith in conte on
what you can do at spurs
such a world-class manager
and
if the rumors are to be believed
spurs are gonna have an active january
window
and that's why i feel that we're gonna
finish above you in the league but it
will be close if you look at the betting
lodge spurs
uh much more more likely than
so you're gonna say spurs are finishing
a button yeah because you know what it
is a couple of injuries a couple of um
players go off form
which can happen i don't think our squad
is like the spur squad or any of the
teams around us to be honest with you so
i'm buzzing this one i'm so happy that
yeah we're doing well now and i'm taking
my fourth spot but the truth is when it
gets into those january february months
especially after this christmas period
then we'll soon see and i think that we
might tiffa is that a word i don't think
so ever
yeah
um
[Laughter]
i don't know why i tried it
we're gonna drop off yeah we're gonna
drop off um i think spurs will finish
above and if you don't it's terrible
if it's stone if you if conte is if big
kante yeah don't it comes here and
doesn't finish above little west ham
with our problems with our chairman and
our rubbish stadium
i'll be hitting you back up mate trust
me there you go that's why i've done
that i don't know what else to say
so we agree on that
yeah unfortunately yeah we agree on it
there you go what a man
and seeing my dad and go oh my god you
know we've done it and then when i had
the cup in my hand
looking up to him like you know think of
the history and the people that have had
their hands on it or the the games that
we've watched together me as a as a kid
and
him as my dad and then for me to finally
hold it was
yeah it's amazing and emotional and
i just got hammered